[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une figure du président de la république
c'est la réforme oui la chienlit non
[Musique]
m
que fera 10 968 l'avenir n'appartient
pas aux hommes et je le prédis pas
pourtant en considérant la façon dont
les choses se présentent
c'est vraiment avec confiance
que j'envisage pour les 12 prochains
mois
l'existence de notre pays mais juin 68
quand on y repense on est surpris que ça
n'ait pas été plus prévu que sanaa était
j'avais beaucoup de relations avec les
milieux professionnels ou syndicaux en
tant que secrétaire d'état à l'emploi je
peux vous dire que je n'en avais vu
aucun qui avant les événements de mai 68
les épreuves je ne sentais pas venir une
grande crise et surtout je ne sente pas
venir une grande crise sociale
je ne suis pas du tout de ce qu'ils
disent j'avais tout prévu vous n'avez
rien prévu qu'ils pouvaient en effet
prévoir l'imprévisible
la france gaullienne prospérer fouettés
par une croissance sans précédent de la
production industrielle l'hexagone se
transforme le pays se modernise
en quelques années le chambardement est
inouï les impératifs économiques priment
les responsables sont convaincus que le
projet technique l'abondance matérielle
résoudront les tensions sociales
les biens d'équipement qui déferle dans
les vitrines donnent l'impression que la
société tout entière est entré dans
l'ère de la consommation c'est aller
vite en besogne
les trente glorieuses ne le sont pas
pour tout le monde l'expansion
miraculeuse creuse également les
inégalités
[Musique]
le phénomène majeur des années 60 il est
là
l'apparition fracassante sur la scène
sociale qu'une génération nombreuses les
enfants du baby boom
la jeunesse n'est pas une classe mais
elle a ses repères série c'est signe de
reconnaissance sa musique
[Musique]
quant à moi
une révolution culturelle où lennon
compte plus que lénine bouscule les
codes sociaux dans la france
pompidolienne règne à un ordre moral
archaïque
[Musique]
dans les lycées les filles doivent
porter des blouses le pantalon n'est pas
autorisée quant à la pilule il a fallu
que quelques pionniers bataille ferme
pour la faire admettre la jeunesse se
révolte contre des interdits d'un autre
âge une rébellion hédoniste
existentielle anti-autoritaire font des
soubresauts 68
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en apparence le boulevard saint-michel
semble immuable en réalité le quartier
latin explose sous les effets de la
croissance des effectifs étudiants ils
ont presque triplé en dix ans
on
se rendait bien compte que l'université
n'était pas adapté aux besoins
que des méthodes d'enseignement que la
façon d'accueillir les étudiants que
l'équipement bibliothèque autre chose
n'était pas au point et on sentait bien
que la jeunesse avait des aspirations
qui n'étaient pas satisfaites
les étudiants ne sont plus des fils à
papa des héritiers l'accès à
l'université s'est démocratisé et les
enfants des couches moyennes sont
particulièrement sensible à la misère
étudiantes ainsi ce milieu par nature
turbulent et frondeurs se transforme en
acteur social en plaque sensible des
contradictions d'une société écartelé
entre modernisation et immobilisme
[Musique]
devant la vague les pouvoirs publics en
lancer la construction de campus à la
périphérie délire
nanterre la folie le nom de la gare est
tout un symbole entre bidonvilles où
croupissent des immigrés et hlm a été
imaginée et construite universal
les étudiants essuie les plâtres et
pataugent dans la boue
faire laboratoire détonnant est un
terrain de prédilection pour l'action
d'une minorité ultra politisé ses
militants on appelle déjà gauchistes qui
rejette aussi bien le modèle occidental
que le système communiste cherche au
delà des frontières la révolution
radicale purs et durs
pour beaucoup la guerre du vietnam
cristallise les valeurs de contestation
de berlin tokyo berkeley ou rome la
fièvre révolutionnaire s'enflamme pour
la lutte d'un petit peuple martyrisé par
la plus grande puissance du monde
les figures boursouflé par le napalm
dans les rizières d'indochine ont
largement contribué à la radicalité
d'une génération en révolte contre la
société
l'humanité avait un visage barbare et
l'occident capitaliste en était coupable
le 20 mars 68 des militants qui avaient
cassé la vitrine de l'american express
sont interpellés pour protester contre
leur arrestation le 22 mars 142
étudiants emmenés par un aucun crédit en
sociologie passe à l'action
[Musique]
c'est cette salle que nous avons occupé
le 22 mars
1968 pourquoi cette salle c'était le
conseil d'administration de l'université
et comme nous avions décidé de porter un
coup mortel à l'administration
universitaire nous sommes entrés dans ce
lieu le leader incontesté et est ce
garçon ce rouquin qui s'appelait cohn
bendit
et qui n'appartenait à aucune des
formations
marxiste ministre hot list maoïstes qui
se disputaient plus ou moins mais qui
était très active est ce qui pouvait les
fédérés du fait qu'il n'appartenait à
aucune d'entre elles et on a su
également qu'il était d'origine
allemande alors à ce moment-là j'ai
demandé à christian fouchet
de d'expulser ce conte petit
la procédure d'expulsion est longue elle
doit être précédée d'une sanction
universitaire qui suit un processus
complexe pendant ce temps le mouvement
du 22 mars se développe
mettez les seuls à parler de la
sexualité à parler de la musique etc et
effectivement c'était quelque chose qui
est très très ressenti d'un coup les
étudiants devaient d'abord ils sont
drôles et deuxièmement il parle de
choses réelles parle de la vie et c'est
ce qui les a attirés
pendant tout le mois d'avril l'escaladé
se poursuit sur le campus jusqu'à la
paralysie
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de prendre les mesures
suivantes
à partir de demain vendredi 3 mai 9h et
jusqu'à nouvel ordre des cours et
travaux pratiques de la faculté seront
suspendus
[Musique]
c'est la plus tard tout a commencé d'une
certaine manière le 3 mai 68 on n'était
pas très nombreux on était quatre ou
cinq sens et on s'était réunis parce que
la veille la faculté de nanterre avait
été fermé il y avait beaucoup
d'agitation nanterre et à la sorbonne il
est vraiment pas grand chose on faisait
passer le temps que l'après midi en
prenant la parole devant cette maigre
foule
faire est dehors il y avait les ondes
occident avec madelin qu'on connaît à
d'autres fonctions aujourd'hui qui nous
en voulaient sans doute et qui faisait
des petites des petites percées dans le
quartier latin craignant une menace
fasciste on a pris quelques
pieds de table et pieds de chaises et
les gens se sont armés peut-être autant
pour s'occuper autre chose à cet instant
le recteur s'inquiète et fait fermer les
amphis
trois centaines d'étudiants se sont
installés dans la cour de la sorbonne
une bonne centaine étaient armés de
gourdins de manches de pioches et même
de pioche c'est à ce moment là que le
recteur de l'université de paris le
couvre entièrement a fait appel au
gardien de la paix municipaux il y a eu
une erreur d'exécution
c'est que dans cette évacuation de là
qu'on verra sorbonne aurait pu se
contenter de pousser les étudiants vers
la sortie et la police les embarquer
pour procéder à ce qu'elle appelle des
vérifications d'identité sur la routine
de la police dans ces cas-là mais
d'autres étudiants qui n'étaient pas
encore entrés dans la sorbonne ou ceux
qui étaient dans la sorbonne mais qui
n'avait fait embarquer dans les paniers
à salade ont cru qu ont emmené leurs
camarades en prison et se sont mis à
lancer des pierres sur les paniers à
salade et ça a été la première et
chauffe
un peu ya dix ans le crâne ouvert par un
pabx et mal préparé une telle
agressivité les forces de l'ordre
cherchent à l'aveuglette et matraques ou
ce qui bouge
quasiment tous les dirigeants politiques
du mouvement se trouvaient dans les
paniers à salade et dans les cas on se
regardait tout 110 m haies mais d'où ça
vient ça peut pas être spontané c'est
pas vous non c'est pas ton organisation
non c'est pas nous le dire j'étais
effectivement spontanée et à mon avis si
la police n'avait pas cerner les
bâtiments il n'avait pas embarqué les
quatre ou cinq cents manifestants qui se
trouvaient dans la cour de la sorbonne
il se serait certainement rien passé
on m'a souvent dit mais si vous n'aviez
pas fait l'erreur de rentrer la sorbonne
on aurait évité mai 68 on aurait évité
le 3 mai mais ce sont arrivés le 4 ou 6
je crois que le moment était venu soit
c'est vrai ça devait arriver
[Applaudissements]
au fond nous
[Musique]
lundi 6 mai dans une sorbonne en état de
siège les troublions de nanterre sont
convoqués devant le conseil de
discipline de l'université
vous pouvez moyart défensif à gérer
votre sentiment je crois qu'il y aura
une manifestation au futur
[Musique]
la veille quatre manifestants arrêtés le
vendredi 3 ont été condamnés à des
peines de prison ferme le mot d'ordre
libérez nos camarades en cette première
semaine de mai pas transformer des
milliers d'étudiants tranquille
préoccuper d'un examen en manifestant
déchaîné
[Musique]
voilà
vers 14h30 au croisement de la rue saint
jacques et du boulevard saint germain
comment sa première bataille de la
journée les manifestants sont refoulés
par la place maubert pendant plusieurs
heures à duels d'artillerie pas b contre
grenade on va les opposer aux policiers
la place des prises et reprises
le préfet de police venu sur place et
stupéfait de la violence des
affrontements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vers 17 heures les voltigeurs décroche
l'unef a lancé depuis la veille un mot
d'ordre de rassemblement à 18 heures
place denfert rochereau des milliers
d'étudiants rejoints par des enseignants
réclament la satisfaction de trois
revendications qui ne changeront plus
réouverture de la sorbonne évacuation
des forces de police et surtout
libération des emprisonnés rue de rennes
le cortège en fût
ce qui est exaltant en toute la première
période de mai c'est le nombre toujours
plus grand le lin l'incessante
augmentation si on veut du nombre des
manifestants ça ça surprend tout le
monde et ça donne effectivement la
possibilité aussi de
résister
et donc de charge et même la police
à saint germain vers 19 heures les
affrontements reprennent
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques jours monsieur le
ministre vous avez déclaré qu'il
s'agissait d'une poignée d'agitateurs et
de responsables du désordre actuel si
vraiment il n'y avait qu'une poignée de
trublion c'est votre terme que vous
aviez employés croyez vous vraiment que
les manifestations aurait revêtu
l'ampleur qu'on a connu vendredi et
aujourd'hui une faut pas exagérer la
proportions que tout cela prend même
dans l'université de paris il ya 160
mille étudiants l'immense majorité de
ces étudiants veut travailler en paix et
les forces de l'ordre n'interviennent
que pour protéger ceux qui veulent
travailler en paix ben nous espérions
dissocier les menèrent qui étaient des
révolutionnaires qui était violent qui
avait depuis longtemps leur plan qui
consistait à changer la société
nous espérions pouvoir les dissocier des
autres n'avait peut-être pas mesuré
la capacité de solidarité qu'avec
qu'avaient les étudiants et qui faisait
que même des étudiants qui
n'approuvaient pas des actes de violence
se sentait instinctivement proches de
ceux d'entre eux qui avaient commis ces
violences partir du moment où l'on
voulait réprimer et c'est à ce moment là
qu'on a senti combien cet engrenage
violence répression solidarisation
ezzeddine engrenage très difficile à
dissocier
[Musique]
deprijk
oui
la bataille de saint germain des prés se
prolonge toute la soirée un commissaire
de police note dans son compte rendu à
plusieurs reprises le barrage a failli
être emportés vers 20 heures la
situation devenait intenable pour le
personnel attaqué de toutes parts
[Musique]
on décompte au soir du 6 mai après douze
heures de bagarre
487 blessés dont deux cents policiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain est plus calme profitant
d'une erreur de la police qui avait
laissé le pont de la concorde ouvert
vingt mille manifestants remontés champs
elysées et entonnent l'internationale
l'un ou retentit d'habitude l'hymne
national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier ministre est parti depuis le
2 mai en voyage officiel en iran et
afghanistan
tandis que georges pompidou fait du
tourisme le gouvernement fait du
surplace
louis joxe gaulliste historique qu
assure l'intérim n'est pas fait pour
l'histoire par nature et privilégie la
conciliation christian fouchet ministre
l'intérieur balance entre la matraquer
ses états d'âme donc l'absence le
silence général l'absence de groupe i do
est là et le manque d'expérience de
christian fouchet fait qu'il ya eu quand
même tout de suite pas mal de flottement
je les ai sentis moi personnellement la
de gaulle se tait officiellement les
chahuts étudiants ne sont pas de son
niveau mais en conseil des ministres le
8 mai ils exigent la fermeté le général
de gaulle considéré que quand on est
dans une situation
de type insurrectionnelle il faut une
très grande fermeté il ne faut en rien
céder devant les meutes car toute
concession qu'on lui fait et le point de
départ de revendications nouvelles de
sorte que on ne peut plus rien arrêté
pourtant l'après-midi à l'assemblée
peyrefitte pressé par foucher risque une
ouverture est ce parce que selon l'ifop
60% des français approuvent les
étudiants l'objectif annoncé par les
autorités universitaires compétentes et
par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale est confirmée ce matin par le
gouvernement a toujours été la reprise
rapide des coûts
mais il est clair que ce qu'il s'agit de
reprendre
ce sont des cours
ce ne sont pas des manifestations de
violence dans les amphithéâtres
curieusement la presse a retenu ça on va
rouvrir sur votre demain et il ya même
une édition spéciale qui a été distribué
à paris le soir même père fille trouvera
la sorbonne le général de gaulle que
j'ai vu le jeudi après-midi
n'était pas du tout satisfait des
réactions de la presse j'ai dû me
montrer devant l'office elle pu montrer
que mes propos étaient extrêmement
prudent et extrêmement équilibrée diva
écouté puisque les conditions ne sont
pas réunies une production du versant
pas
l'elysée ne veut pas entendre parler du
moindre compromis et pourtant c'est le
moment car le mouvement étudiant depuis
deux jours marquent le pas et se cherche
de sit in improvisé devant la sorbonne
en meetings enflammés il apparaît à
cohn-bendit et à ses camarades que
devant l'intransigeance du pouvoir sur
leurs trois revendications il ne reste
qu'une escalade
nous étions persuadés disons au 22 mars
que si on voulait vraiment
10 ont
gagné sur nos revendications
les trois revendications du début
l'on ne pouvait gagner que en augmentant
la la mobilisation donc en radicalisant
le mouvement sur ses revendications
[Musique]
vendredi 10 mai 18h ils sont des
dizaines de milliers dont beaucoup de
très jeunes lycéens au rendez-vous de
denfert chacun pressent que cette
journée sera décisive mais nul n'imagine
à quel point ce jour là en effet
l'histoire est également au rendez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vers 20 heures le cortège remonte le
boulevard saint-michel passe devant la
sorbonne sévèrement bouclé et s'arrête
devant le luxembourg et puis là l'idée a
germé je crois d'ailleurs qu'elle doit
venir plus ou moins ou de cohn bendit ou
en tout cas du du 22 mars du mouvement
du 22 mars c'était de dire finalement
ils occupent la sorbonne en occupe la
police et ont leurs cercles à notre tour
au bout d'une heure ou deux heures on a
entendu un drôle de son un espèce de
bruit métallique frappant le sol et on a
compris que les manifestants
spontanément s'est ému a dépavé pour
construire des barricades et ont assisté
à ce spectacle hallucinant de milliers
d'étudiants formant des chaînes un peu
comme sur les barrages de chine
populaire cours
édifié des barricades à partir de pavés
et de tout ce qui pouvait servir pour
élever des murs et à une vitesse
incroyable insoupçonnable des barricades
de dos trois mètres de haut se sont
élevées dans la plupart des rues lui en
particulier rue gay lussac
il régnait tout autour de la sorbonne et
sur la montagne sainte-geneviève une
incroyable atmosphère de kermesse de
fait voir de carnaval
tous tous ces jeunes
étaient convaincus qu'il allait
l'emporter il ya véritablement le
sentiment que si on restait là un peu
comme les trompettes de jéricho si on
restait là suffisamment de temps on
allait obtenir le départ des crs la
réouverture de l'assaut de la sorbonne
et satisfaction sur toute la ligne les
barricades s'élève le gouvernement lui
flotte entre toutes les attitudes la
police campe larmes au pied à un jet de
pierres des manifestants
et mes collaborateurs et moi nous avions
espéré que les très jeunes 12 ans 14 ans
15 ans allait rentrer chez eux gentiment
or malheureusement un levier très beaux
ils sont restés là et déclencher des
forces d'opérations de police avec de
très jeunes mêler aux plus grands
c'est préoccupant
en attendant dans les coulisses se
déroule plusieurs négociations
parallèles c'est tout sauter sur
l'occasion quand touraine m'a proposé la
négociation
avec le recteur
ce lutin doué génial qu'est cohn-bendit
avait réussi à se faufiler
jusque auprès du recteur qui ne savait
pas du tout qu'il avait qu'on ne l'a dit
en face de lui et on a appris par la
radio par une radio périphérique que
compétitive dans le bureau du recteur
j'ai aussi rappelé le recteur jeudi mais
vous savez que vous avez comme l'a dit
en face de vous on ne sait pas possible
mais ce n'est pas vrai monsieur le
ministre vous vous trompez si vous
n'avez pas un aucun face de vous une
figureront et il m'a dit bah si
les négociations ne pouvait échouer
c'était trop tard ou trop tôt
chez moi 2 jours du matin qu'ils aient
dû dire peyrefitte qu' il fallait en
finir parce que
je n'avais pas de rôle est rassuré pour
remplacer dédé policier fatigué et puis
qu'on avait quand même à ce moment là
dix ou quinze ou vingt barricades édifié
autour de autour du panthéon que c'était
ça pourrait pas durer ainsi
à 2 heures du matin c'est l'assaut
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est d'autre les matches
oui
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
à l'aube les forces de l'ordre ont
repris des barricades après le soulier
le combat commence alors dans les
ruelles de 5e arrondissement une chasse
aux manifestants les fuyards sont
poursuivies dans les appartements les
escaliers et matraqué avec sauvagerie
les passages à tabac dans les cars ou
les commissariats sont nombreux
il ya des centaines d'arrestations des
centaines de blessés certains dans un
état grave mais par miracle il n'y a pas
de morts
je comprends les étudiants soit heurter
ou lendemain des événements qu'ils ont
vu le côté dramatique puis-je dire
encore que ce matin un journal le titre
un peu méchamment n'est ce pas le préfet
de police est satisfait simplement parce
qu'en effet j'ai marqué et non pas ma
satisfaction mais tout de même ce qui
aurait pu être ma désolation si nous
avions eu des morts cette nuit et il
faut penser que plus d'une fois on a été
à un doigt d'avoir ce genre de
conclusion dramatique
or nous l'avons évite les
à 6h du matin joxe révèle the rule qui
s'était couché à 10h et l'informent des
événements de la nuit l'ordre règne à
paris mais à quel prix les journaux les
radios qui n'ont cessé d'émettre font
état de la violence policière le pignon
opa skull
[Musique]
la cgt jusque là hostiles un mouvement
anarchique réagi et appel pour le 13 mai
à une grève générale et à une
manifestation cette nuit n'a pas été
mais banal et la violence
contre les étudiants avaient réellement
modifié même l'état d'esprit d'une
grande partie de l'opinion publique qui
pouvait s'interroger les jours
précédents sur la nature de ce mouvement
étudiant mais qui l'a n'accepte pas con
con matraque aussi violemment
la fière étudiante est en train de se
communiquer au corps social le
gouvernement de la pente en perçu il
s'apprête à circonscrire l'incendié du
quartier latin alors que la mèche cours
déjà
je
on
va écouter je n'ai pas grand chose à
dire sinon que je viens d'accomplir un
voyage
qui était peut-être un peu fatigant
mais qui était étonnant par le capital
de sympathie et de respect pour la
france qui l'a révélé dans ces pays
d'iran et d'afghanistan
maintenant je rentre
décidé à essayer de développer nos
relations de toute espèce avec ces deux
pays aient décidé aussi vous vous en
doutez à préoccuper des affaires
françaises
sur laquelle j'ai un certain nombre
d'idées enfin je vous le dirai pas tout
de suite georges pompidou
arrivé d'afghanistan
calme reposé bronzer alors que nous
avions passé des nuits
à dormir et nous devons être pas les
décomposer à côté de lui il nous a
réunis il nous a dit voilà mon plan et
je me suis dit de toute façon générale
va l'envoyer sur des roses pompidou a en
une de miers réussi à retourner général
de gaulle lequel par la suite leur
prochaine doit forcer la main en mettant
sa démission dans la balance j'ai décidé
que la survole serait librement ouverts
à partir de lundi
les cours reprenant à la diligence du
recteur et des doyens
à partir de lundi également la cour
d'appel pourra conformément à la loi
statuer sur les demandes de libération
des étudiants condamnés georges pompidou
dès son retour a joué une carte tactique
qu'il celle de durée de faire le gros
dos car il se disait l'opinion publique
est contre nous il faut lui laisser le
temps de réaliser ce qu'est mai 68 et où
cela va l'amener et s'inquiètent tout
nos tactiques à matignon son action
était fondée sur une intuition
c'est que il fallait tout fait pour
éviter les drames et laisser le
mouvement s'essouffle et le général de
gaulle considéré que tout ça c'était un
désaveu du gouvernement donc un désaveu
de lui même le chef de l'état c'était un
changement complet de politique
et quand on change complètement de
politique au cours d'une période de type
insurrectionnelle eh bien on n'existe
plus le gouvernement se mette à genoux
et il est incapable ensuite de reprendre
les choses en main il m'a pas dit c'est
du pétain mais il a dit c'est toujours
la facilité comme au moment de la
réoccupation de la rive gauche du rhin
comme au moment de munich et comme au
moment de la débâcle la facilité
on renonce à se battre parce que c'est
plus facile
aussitôt ouverte la sorbonne est occupée
au son du piano dijon
[Musique]
oh
à
10 ans ça suffit ils sont 300 milles a
défilé de la gare de l'est à denfert
rochereau la poignée d'enragés s'est
faite multitude les excités de nanterre
et la sorbonne si isolé quelques jours
plus tôt ont fait des petits et des gros
scores de salariés ému par la répression
policière ne peuvent s'empêcher de tirer
la leçon de la semaine écoulée l'action
a payé devant la résolution des
manifestants le pouvoir après avoir dit
nos revendications étudiantes a fini par
céder les plus déterminés des jeunes
ouvriers médite l'exemple des
guérilleros du quartier latin
[Musique]
les dirigeants de la cgt ont retrouvé le
sourire ils sont en terrain connu
j'ai participé à beaucoup de
manifestations au cours de mon existence
depuis ma jeunesse c'était une des plus
extraordinaires que j'ai vécu c'était le
maximum de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
même au delà de ce que vous pouvez
espérer
[Musique]
une seule ombre au tableau pour les
communistes la présence au premier rang
de cohn-bendit le troublion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la fin de la manifestation
cohn bendit entraîne quelques milliers
de personnes jusqu'aux champs de mars
histoire de prolonger un peu la fête
[Applaudissements]
le mardi 14 au matin le général de
gaulle s'envole pour un voyage officiel
en roumanie
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes fait tous les roumains
au vibrant rhône
[Applaudissements]
pendant l'absence du chef de l'état
georges pompidou se saisit des commandes
il est entouré de sa garde rapprochée
jaubert balladur juillet chirac qui ne
manque pas d'occupations à l'époque
monsieur davidoff qui est un important
producteur de cigares venait de publier
un livre c'était juste pendant ces jours
là et non monsieur pompidou qui était un
grand amateur de cigares
monsieur pierre juillet qui est un autre
amateur de cigares
discuter
la perte de vue sur ce livre sur les
mérites comparés des différentes
catégories de cigares moi j'ai horreur
des cigares je ne suis pas fumeur de
cigares alors j'écoutais cela je
m'instruis et naturellement des jamais
été aussi savant sur les cigares que
pendant cette période
et puis quand on avait fini de discuter
des signes attendant les choses on
discutait de chasse moi je ne suis pas
chasseur g pompidou était un excellent
fusil comme vous le savez monsieur
juillet également moi j'étais pas
chasseur je me suis également instruit
sur la chasse pendant cette période les
14 mai devant les députés l'ancien
normalien pompidou n'hésite pas à
prendre du recul et de la hauteur
jeunesse universitaire en tout cas se
trouvent désemparés
genevois de précédent dans notre
histoire
qu'en cette période désespérée que fut
le xvème siècle ou s'effondraient les
structures du moyen-âge et où déjà les
étudiants se révoltaient en sorbonne à
ce stade ce n'est plus croyez moi le
gouvernement qui est en cause ni les
institutions ni même la france c'est
notre civilisation elle-même
à l'heure même où pompidou parle à
l'assemblée les ouvriers de sud aviation
à bout du nez près de nantes vote la
grève et occupent l'usiné
le lendemain la grève des marins renault
cléon près de rouen puis à sandouville
et flore
[Musique]
et jeune ouvrier de 20 ou 25 ans de
cléon de sud aviation
n'avait aucune raison de ne pas avoir
des revendications puisque on cédait
tout ce qu'ils voulaient à leurs
camarades étudiants
à billancourt en fin d'après-midi le 16
les débrayages commence
et que chez vous c'est la grande tous
les fronts ils font la grève allait dans
tous les coins notre secteur éditeur de
sortir est en fait que je suis arrivé
ici tout le monde sortait de tous les
coins juin au bureau ça me colle tout on
était un peu dépassé par ils tous ces
gens là qui sortait sa théâtre animé
petit à petit dans la mine karine
dubernet et j'avais l'impression en tout
cas comment après ça on a repris on voit
dans la première
démo mais n'empêche que les gens y
dégringolait est déroulé sur le coup
c'était rapide et des copains mais par
la suite
[Musique]
on est monté dans l'île seguin
qui est derrière nous et on a décidé
avec toute une série d'autres salariés
d'autres ateliers
d'occuper
pour la nuit
l'entreprise et de d'envoyer une
délégation la direction pour obtenir
l'ouverture des négociations
premièrement l'augmentation générale des
salaires pour toutes les catégories
et pas un salaire en dessous de 100
mille anciens francs pour l'ouvrier
spécialisé
deuxièmement la réduction du temps de
travail sans perte de salaire est
précisément le 17 mai au matin là
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus ce sont les
salariés qui réunit dans l'île seguin
ont décidé à main levée
d'occuper l'entreprise
le démarrage de la grève chez renault
billancourt a été ressenti la sérénité
de la cité en exemple été ressentie par
tous comme en quelque sorte un exemple
et un signal
la grève se répand comme une tâche
d'huile le 17 une cinquantaine d'usinés
d'occuper on dénombre 200 milles
grévistes
la cfdt se lance tout de suite dans la
bataille
les consignes sont données à toutes nos
organisations
de prendre en rapport avec les
travailleurs toutes les dispositions
pour donner le maximum d'ampleur
possible au mouvement de grève
actuellement décidé la cgt prend la tête
d'un mouvement qui a démarré sans elle
les trains s'arrêtent le pays roule vers
la grève générale le 18 au soir il y a
deux millions de grévistes
[Musique]
pour les révolutionnaires de la sorbonne
la grève est un cadeau du vieux marx
saisie par les frissons du grand soir il
rêve d'alliance avec le prolétariat
mythique paré de toutes les vertus et
surtout de celle de faire la révolution
afin de réaliser cette fameuse jonction
étudiants ouvriers un cortège étudiant
des bulls aux portes de renault que les
militants cgt boucle soigneusement pas
question de se laisser contaminer
dès le début il ne pouvions pas prendre
le risque de donner le moindre prétexte
au pouvoir
d'engager une répression violente
contre la grève des salariés sous
prétexte d'un incident qui serait arrivé
donc moi qu'on aurait pu grossir ils
vont lui dire voilà ça mais la sécurité
du pays en danger ceci et cela parce que
des barricades
d'étudiants
un courageuse
alors alors c'est leur signification
elles sont ce qu'elles sont on les
traite avec des coups de gourdins et des
grenades qui font pleurer les barricades
ouvrière elles sont faites autrement
dans l'histoire et on ne se contente pas
de grenade qui font pleurer
personnellement j'ai toujours essayé de
dire qu'il y à deux mouvements et que
ces deux mouvements ne peuvent pas
unifiées comme ça veut dire il ya tout
ce mouvement qu'on appelle la révolte de
la genèse qui exprimait une volonté d'un
certain type de mode de vie d'une
transformation de la vie donc d'une
remise en cause culturelle en ce sens le
plus large du terme de la société et un
mouvement ouvrier qui était un mouvement
beaucoup plus traditionnel camp bendit
qui s je crois que vous me parlez de ce
mouvement qui a été créée si récemment à
grand renfort de publicité je n'en dirai
rien d'autre que à propos de ces
dernières démarches et de ses dernières
décisions que les travailleurs voient
d'un mauvais oeil les interventions qui
se produisent et qui prétendent se
substituer à leurs responsables pour
diriger leur lutte la classe ouvrière
mal des majeurs elle n'a nul besoin
d'immixion des gérances extérieur pour
prendre des responsabilités qu'elles à
apprendre à la période présente
entre les communistes et les gauchistes
le contentieux est ancien plus d'une
fois les gros bras du service d'ordre
viennent aux mains comme ici le 1er mai
68 les groupes d'extrême gauche sont
issus du pc auquel il reproche son
alignement sur moscou sa sclérose
intellectuelle son réformisme pépère son
stalinisme indécrottable et communiste
rejette le discours l'idéologie et
l'activisme souvent violents des
gauchistes il se méfie des mouvements
minoritaires qui échappe à son emprise
[Musique]
et puis le 3 mai l'article de georges
marchais dans l'humanité dénonçant
l'anarchiste allemand cohn-bendit a jeté
de l'huile sur le feu dès 2010
exactement ce qu'il voulait dire un
artiste parce que l'anarchie c'est la
pagaille et ça ne peut pas être sérieux
alors il faut faire attention et puis
allemand parce qu'il n'est pas français
et ce ne sont pas tous même les
allemands qui vont décider du sort de la
france et la classe ouvrière française
voilà
c'était tout et est à la fois et cela
montrait bien
la manière d'appréhender un tel
mouvement de mes étudiants est
authentique communiste kke
anticapitaliste
si je suis rapide et rusé confinés dans
leurs ghettos les étudiants transforme
la sorbonne on nous sort de communes que
l'on visite bientôt comme le musée
grévin de la révolution des dizaines
d'années dans ce territoire libéré de
toute contrainte jour et nuit on refait
le monde litanie d enthousiasme
désillusion désespoir et structures de
l'université ne nous satisfont pas
elles ne correspondent absolument lui à
la société actuelle et cette société
actuelle ne correspond absolument plus
aux besoins de la pire et c'est cet
avenir que nous qui sommes jeunes
essayons de créer essayons de faire
progresser nous ne voulons pas que les
choses restent comme elles sont parce
que comme elles sont elles ne sont pas
bonnes
des écrivains marguerite duras en tête
trempent leur plume dans l'encré rouge
jouer avec les mots c'est leur métier
sur le gaullisme
la violence c'est de gaulle le pouvoir
chez vous pour les travailleurs soyez
réalistes demandez l'impossible
une autre sur la qualification radio la
radio empoisonne la grève
spontanée ou réfléchie les fameux slogan
de mai traduisent une extraordinaire
libération de la parole quand on aurait
tort de sourire cette révolution des
mots ce défoulement verbales contre
lesdites sociétés matérialistes et
cloisonnée annonce une révolution
culturelle qui restera la véritable
révolution de mai
[Musique]
dans les quartiers
tél
avoir deux
l'âge
à
c'est à l'odéon occupé dès le 15 mai que
le niagara de parole va trouver sa chute
dans ce théâtre des fantasmes
transformer en vivant s'opère une vaste
psychanalyse public
chacun vient raconter sa vie véritable
petit show avant l'heure cathodique
et moi qui
ai pas jamais j'arrive au niveau des
eaux
est malgré tout donner par amina oui moi
je suis garçon qui apaiserait maître
d'hôtel et ben on n'allait plus le
gouffre en effet 12 ans le travail
d'aller prendre des cours à la sorbonne
non c'est pas vrai
j'adore dit de faire quelque chose
malgré mes trois cent mille francs par
mois et bah je n'ai rien presse et
respirer et mon émotion mais c'est comme
ça en france voilà c'est tout
on veut vivre les vieillards comme un
marché dans un couloir où une veillée à
côté tout droit ce qu'on veut c'est que
dans la possibilité de vivre avec ou
sans fort et avec notre famille
[Applaudissements]
rares sont les observateurs qui
perçoivent delà des outrances et des
caricatures le sens de cet inconscient
collectif sa portée est plus grande
pourtant qu'un jet de pavé le pouvoir
lui n'y voit que les signes de
l'infantilisme d'un mouvement qui ne
comprend pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 18 mai dans la soirée de gaulle
revient de roumanie informé de
l'évolution de la situation il a abrégé
son séjour le chef de l'état est furieux
il suffit que de gaulle s'en aille et
tout s'écroule glapit t-il devant ses
ministres au garde à vous le général
retrouve un langage de militaires et
chacun en prend pour son grade
[Musique]
puis de gaulle emmène avec lui pop et
doux jusqu'à l'elysée l'explication
entre les deux hommes est franche
brutale presque au point que pompidou
offre sa démission on n'abandonne pas
son poste en pleine bataille tranche
général
[Musique]
le lendemain de gaulle convoque à
l'elysée les responsables du maintien de
l'ordre au pidoux messmer foucher
grimaud
il est très mécontent il est très
colérique il à leur teint rouge d'abord
dès l'entrée moi j'étais un peu gêné
parce que j'étais le seul nom ministre
dans ce dans ce petit conclave et le
général nous accueillent comme ça la
porte de son bureau en cire à la main
mais
pas le moindre sourire ni quoi que ce
soit et puis aussitôt qu'il s'assoie
le ton
vis-à-vis de fouché qui l'interrogent
est tout de suite assez dur il ya
monsieur mise intérieur je ne pense pas
que vous ayez rien rien à m'apprendre
que je ne sache déjà des choses comme ça
ce qui n'est pas très gentil et
l'atelier s'est dit j'ai pris mes
résolutions et suffit comme ça
maintenant on libère sans bonne ce soir
lyon demain après la réunion pompidou ne
révèlent rien de la colère du chef de
l'état
je ne pense pas n'est ce pas mais si je
vais vous résumer l'opinion du président
de la république c'est la réforme oui la
chienlit non
comme nous avons vidé le général et
comme il y avait un ordre peschier
formelle du chef de l'état je n'ai pas
désobéir donc je prends quelques
dispositions je commence à étudier
comment on pourrait faire une
intervention à l'odéon dans la nuit
georges pompidou était persuadé que s'il
n'y avait pas d'effusion de sang la
faire se finirait par se déliter et ne
lancerait pas de traces profondes que si
au contraire on employait la force et
que cette force aboutissaient à des
morts et des blessés au contraire il y
aurait là une une sorte de deux
blessures qui ceci crée des risques et
qui aurait beaucoup de mal à se
cicatriser dans la soirée je suis appelé
par michel jobert qu'il me dit voilà ce
qu'ont vision est très embêté parce
qu'on a essayé de faire revenir le
général sur ses décisions il veut rien
entendre
est ce que vous pourriez vous ou non de
vos connaissances de préfet de police
est appelée l'elysée appelé bien leurs
tricots pour dire que c'est pas possible
j'appelais le bernard tricot
je crois que le général n'étaient pas
encore couchés c'était sur le problème
des 10 48 s'annonce énorme si dorota il
va donc voir général il me rappelle un
demi heure après les gens en général
vous laisse le soin de d'apprécier mais
pas au delà de trois jours général de
gaulle à l'essai georges pompidou
essayer sa tactique et puis il était
décidé à le juger au résultat
de gaulle veut agir pompidou veut
attendre de gaulle tonnes de sa grosse
voix pompidou fait le gros dos il y à
bien au sommet de l'état divergent sur
la manière de résoudre la crise
mais le gouvernement a les questions
plus graves à régler que la sorbonne où
le déaut
dans cette troisième semaine de mai le
pays est paralysé par la plus grande
grève de son histoire 7 millions de
salariés ont cessé le travail il ya plus
de trains de bus de métros les
entreprises se met en congé l'autorité
de l'état est en peine liquéfaction
l'économie a plongé dans le coma les
ministères se vident passe un pouvoir un
puissant sens dresse un autre la cgt
gère la grève et le pays mais veillent à
ne pas franchir la limite entre grèves
générales et grève insurrectionnelle si
la population la plus à souffrir de la
grève
personne n'a manqué de pain personne ne
monte en général de ravitaillement
personne n'a manqué d'eau personne n'a
manqué d'électricité
il ya eu un boum ni de services médicaux
ou hospitaliers fin et c'est
tout cela ni non plus de journaux
tout cela
alors que tout le monde était en grève
tout cela a dépendu des décisions prises
dans les organisations de la cgt
la grève change la france on apprend à
vivre sans essence sans banques sans
grands magasins les mentalités évoluent
également à toute vitesse dans
l'allégresse des occupations et le rêve
d'une autre vie
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est absolument aberrant
que dans une société qu'on dit de
progrès est-ce qu'on reparle beaucoup de
l'association des loisirs et on n'est
pas idiot les premières sont pas idiots
effectivement on est dans une ère où il
y à une progression énorme une évolution
cette formidable des techniques des
sciences et en fin de compte qu'est ce
qu'on a qu'est ce qu'ils ont qu'est-ce
qu'on leur donne en fonction de cette
évolution et bien rien c'est
indéfinissable esprit de mai qui
bouleverse les relations entre les
hommes commencent à souffler sur la
société française ce n'est qu'un début
la fièvre c'est en gagnent au delà des
ouvriers le plaza est en grève les
écrivains les footballeur les acteurs
les architectes les médecins tout le
monde est touché par la grâce de la
contestation à cannes il faut godard
interrompre et estivale
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez d'arrivée avec les héliades
ouvriers et vous a parlé
[Musique]
même le rtf la chasse gardée du pouvoir
entre dans la ronde les journalistes
refusent la parole imposé si même la
télé ne parle plus aux listes
[Applaudissements]
et nous affirmons hautement
que nous sommes décidés à éclats mais
les responsabilités du pouvoir
à l'assemblée l'opposition déposent une
motion de censure qui repoussait mais
qui se soucie de cette agitation
d'aquarium alors que le pays vote une
motion de défiance
désormais les choses importantes se
passe en coulisse pompidou sait que le
salut est dans la négociation avec le
pouvoir réel
pompidou le premier ministre a cherché à
nouer défilent avec les syndicats est
cgt en particulier pour engager une
négociation et chercher une issue comme
on le fait dans tout conflit et pendant
toute cette période j'ai eu des contacts
c'est vrai je peux le dire aujourd'hui
puisque ils ont été relatées dans les
livres ou dans des journaux avec des
représentants de la cgt contacts
officieux que j'ai pris dans des
conditions dans les circonstances qui
parfois est un peu folklorique je ne
connais personne
à la cgt qui est parti à quelque chose
de ce genre il y en a ajouté un
entretien étonnant square d'anvers
un autre jour je suis allé
petite chambre
un quartier éloigné du centre de paris
qui était sous les combles 6e étage et
j'ai été conduit par deux personnages au
faciès inquiétant et qui m'y attendais
pour
qu'ils n'étaient que des gens du service
d'ordre de la cgt parfaitement
sympathique et parfaitement inoffensive
naturellement enfin non le physique
peut-être un physique impressionnant et
dans la période un peu inquiétant 1 et
qui par des petits couloirs et les
escaliers des conduits jusqu'à
c'est une petite chambre j'ai rencontré
un responsable de cette centrale
syndicale je le contraire complètement
saugrenue je vois pas comment on peut
imaginer que nous nous prêtent au rayon
à des histoires de ce genre alors que un
coup de téléphone pour nous dire
officiellement on propose de négocier
donc besoin de rien d'autre nous sommes
contre les conversations occultes
pendant ce temps le mouvement étudiant
patine le 20 mai cohn-bendit pas pour
l'allemagne
j'ai craqué personnellement
baer je sais plus quand le 20 mai
parce que justement donc c'était je me
retrouvais si tu veux devant un
personnage historique qui m'avait quand
même complètement coupée de plus en plus
de mon origine politique je devais
remplir un rôle politique
je ne voulais pas assumer comme ça
[Musique]
le ministre de l'intérieur christian
fouchet profite de son absence et du
fait qu'il est allemand pour l'interdire
de séjour en france
quelqu'un touche et me l'a dit
d'ailleurs dans le temps un peu gêné m'a
dit on a vu le métier obligé de 2 m 2 de
prendre cet arrêté parce que cette même
inadmissible et insupportable
[Applaudissements]
cohn bendit se présentent à la frontière
française et il est refoulé
l'interdiction de séjour donne naissance
au slogan le plus populaire de mai nous
sommes tous des juifs allemands la
décision du gouvernement par allumer
l'émeute l'unef appelle à manifester le
24 mai
[Applaudissements]
c'est également le 24 mai que le général
de gaulle doit parler au pays il a fait
son diagnostic la france souffre d'une
crise de civilisation
il faut y répondre par un vaste dessein
le 24 mai ce sera quitte ou double
[Musique]
au pied de la grosse horloge et sont des
dizaines de milliers le préfet grimaud a
autorisé un rassemblement pas une
manifestation tout le quartier est
bouclé
[Applaudissements]
les délégations arrivent les unes après
les autres
[Applaudissements]
en un seul plan tout le jeune cinéma
français mal rennais rivette il ne
manque pas une bobine
même les amis de mitterrand sont là et
astier et renoue rousselet au coude à
coude ne vont pas jusqu'à brandir le
poing
à 20 heures de gaulle parle tout le
monde comprend évidemment
quelle est la portée des actuels
événement
universitaire
[Musique]
une mutation de notre société
mutations qui doit comporter
la participation plus effective de
chacun à la marche et au résultat
l'activité qui lui concerne le direct
[Applaudissements]
j'ai décidé
de soumettre au suffrage de la nation
un projet de loi par lequel je lui
demande
de donner à l'état
est d'abord à son chef un mandat pour la
rénovation
français
et
par un vote
au cas
où votre réponse serait non
il va de soi que je n'assumerai pas plus
longtemps ma fonction
cette fois la magie des mots n'a pas
suffi adieu de gaulle cris des milliers
de poitrines et tout de suite
l'atmosphère se charge d'électricité
mais la police intervient très vite pour
dégager les abords de la place de la
bastille
[Applaudissements]
la manifestation éclatante au départ qui
se répand dans toute la rive droite
[Applaudissements]
la nuit du 24 mai j'ai vraiment celle
qui me laisse alors le plus le plus
mauvais souvenir c'est la seule nuit où
j'ai eu un moment l'impression que
peut-être ça pourrait nous échapper
c'est la seule fois
[Applaudissements]
enfin à aucun moment je n'ai pensé que
la rue allait renverser le gouvernement
de la république je suis vraiment
j'avais été débordé en me retirer mais
pouvoir et en donner les pouvoirs les
autorités militaires j'ai prévu par la
loi et par la constitution j'ai pas du
tout est légal
[Musique]
les manifestants ont reflué vers le
quartier latin transformée en énorme
champ de bataille arbres sied panneaux
de signalisation arrachés la violence
atteint cette nuit son paroxysme
a lyon un commissaire de police et tué
par un camion lâché sur les forces de
l'ordre
au matin le ministre de l'intérieur
dénonce la pègre sortis des basses eaux
la pègre si nous répond des étudiants
mais le coeur n'y est plus plus personne
ne contrôle personnes et les français
commencent à prendre peur de cette
escalade de violence l'opinion publique
inquiète veut être rassurée mais elles
doutent des capacités du chef de l'état
à maîtriser la situation paris à feu et
à sang et des phrases creuses sur la
participation décidément le vieux a
perdu la main s'inquiètent les tenants
de l'ordre
son discours du 24 mai on le sait bien
et je n'ai rien à ajouter là dessus est
tombé tout à fait à côté
ça a été de la part de ceux qui l'aiment
et bien disons une attention polie de la
part des autres l'opposition où la
dérision ça n'a rien donné
et bien ce discours du 24 mai c'était à
mes yeux une parole juste qui sonne faux
c'était un discours profond calé au fond
des choses
mais qui n'était pas recevable parce
qu'il n'était pas du tout en phase avec
ce que les français attendaient du
général de gaulle à ce moment là il a eu
le sentiment qu'ils ne comprenaient plus
très bien il a dit lui même la situation
est insaisissable et par conséquent il a
été porté à l'essai et à son premier
ministre responsable
la liberté d'action
de gaulle a échoué reste pompidou le
premier ministre a tout misé sur la
rencontre sociale au sommet il veut
dissocier les revendications ouvrières
de la contestation étudiante s'il
parvient à un accord avec la cgt la
partie est gagnée le jeune secrétaire
d'état à l'emploi jacques chirac a
préparé le terrain
samedi 25 mai à 15 heures les
délégations syndicales et patronales
arrive rue de grenelle au rendez-vous de
la dernière chance
[Musique]
le premier ministre flanqué de son
conseiller social edouard balladur est
décidé à disputer tout le week-end s'il
le faut
[Musique]
à grenelle seul confie doubs a parlé moi
j'étais présent chirac étaient présents
mais nous étions silencieux nous
parlions avec pompidou nous nous
concertions dents pendant les
suspensions de séance mais en séance lui
seul parlait et c'était normal il avait
la pleine responsabilité de la manoeuvre
nous avons tous été observée chez
georges pompidou
son pragmatisme son réalisme car en
définitive il s'est beaucoup plus
adressés aux interlocuteurs de la cgt
parce qu'ils savaient qu'ils étaient les
principaux animateurs et conducteurs de
la grève peu aux autres organisations
syndicales les trois principaux
interlocuteurs c'était le gouvernement
le cnpf que la série était tous les
syndicats ont parlé mais c'est vrai que
la cgt faisait part d'un poids
particulier par la force des choses
j'avais eu l'occasion à ce moment là de
prendre des contacts notamment avec la
cgt au terme desquelles des contacts je
dirais de couloir au terme desquelles
nous devions fixé je ne peux pas citer
les chiffres peu importe
le smic qu'un certain taux
et puis c'est d'accord je dirais
moralement conclut nous entrons en
séance
je rends compte monsieur pompidou du
résultat de cet entretien de cette
petite négociation
qui était pas un élément d'une
négociation globale naturellement
et ont fait un tour de table et à ce
moment là quelle n'a pas été notre
étonnement de voir
le représentant de force ouvrière
dont on pensait qu'il s'associerait à
cette demande dira nous pas du tout nous
on veut le smic et à 3 francs ce qui
était supérieur à ce que l'on avait
envisagé et
de surprise a été encore plus grand
d'entendre le représentant du cnpf
répondre eh bien tout à fait d'accord
pour trois francs il est vrai que durant
la négociation
jacques chirac l'occasion d'une
suspension de séance m'a demandé de la
part de georges pompidou une
conversation personnelle que j'ai
accepté
c'était pour me faire savoir quelles
étaient les concessions ultime
auquel pouvait aboutir le gouvernement
il y avait le smic il y avait les
ordonnances la sécurité sociale que nous
continuons dont nous continuons à exiger
l'abrogation et j'ai fait savoir change
par pompidou par chirac interposés qui
n'était pas question de conclure la
négociation à ce niveau car notre
revendication du spic était bien au delà
des 2 francs 80 je crois que le goût man
se proposait est accepté comme ultime
concession
au petit matin dimanche 26 mai de
négociations sont suspendues excepté sur
le smic on n'a guère avancé pour écouter
je n'ai pas grand chose à dire je crois
que nous avons laisse parler pendant 13
heures ce qui représente par conséquent
la preuve que tout beaucoup de questions
ont été abordées que les discussions ont
été approfondies et
nous vous pouvez conclure qu'elles n'ont
pas reculé et qu'elles ont je crois
pouvoir affirmer progresser bien entendu
la séance est suspendue et nous nous
retrouvons demain plus tôt aujourd'hui
après midi ici même je vous remercie
le marathon reprend le dimanche à 17
heures on piétine autour du tapis vert
mais dans les couloirs les conciliabules
vont bon train jacques chirac et georges
s'est dit en particulier négocier en
tête à tête vers laumes un compromis est
trouvé
[Musique]
nous avons donc pensé qu' il a peut-être
d'un commun accord avec mon bijou que
la seule solution qui se présentait à
nous dans ces contrées ces circonstances
nous syndicat lui représentant du
gouvernement à l'occasion expliquait au
cnpf qu'il fallait pas tergiversé lésiné
pour conclure un certain nombre de
choses positivement de la seule solution
c'était d'aboutir un résultat de te
trouver la solution négociée à ce
problème c'est ce qui s'est produit nous
sommes arrivés un ensemble de
conclusions positives et dont on peut
dire qu'elle constitue un accord c'est
le caractère extraordinairement sérieux
de la crise actuelle qui seul a permis
d'aboutir à des concessions aussi
important
ça coûte cher c'est vrai mais faut
savoir terminer leur machination
il faut savoir le prix que l'on peut
payer alors qu'on puisse utiliser
je ne mettrai pas
j'estime ce que nous avons atteint un
résultat de première importance et qui
doit permettre la reprise du travail et
dans des conditions aussi rapide que le
permet la technique si la décision
consiste à apprécier les résultats d'une
façon positive à moins que on estime
pouvoir aller plus loin ce moment la
reprise du travail ne saurait tarder
nous avons cru le lundi matin que les
choses prenaient un bon départ puisque
nous étions parvenus à un accord
dans le petit matin du grenelle l'équipe
au pidoux croit avoir gagné c'est guy
parent pour l'usiné renault nul ne doute
à matignon qu'il va faire accepter par
les ouvriers les résultats des
négociations on faisait un meeting tous
les jours tous les matins alors il y
avait plus ou moins de monde mais là
évidemment avec grenelle et on a eu un
meeting de 25 25 mille salariés en
pleurant encore une fois et on a donc
décidé de leur proposer de poursuivre la
grève
et avant que georges séguy à arrive
les salariés avaient déjà jeté sur notre
proposition la poursuite de l'occupation
[Applaudissements]
m
pas grave et poursuivi à l'unanimité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rencontre les joueurs je sais guy sur la
passerelle de l'île soya qui y venaient
et il est venu rendre compte finalement
de ce qui s'était passé à grenelle
chers camarades
vers le neuf heures durant
quasiment inévitable
nous avons livré bataille
face à un adversaire tenace ne nous
méprenons pas car rien n'est signé
[Applaudissements]
car le gouvernement
il est né votre question que nous
signons camps le gouvernement
nous a demandé
si au terme de 16 de ces longs travaux
de discussion
nous avions lancé lors de reprise du
travail
nous leur avons répondu
comme nous n'avons jamais lancée à
l'échelle fédérale le mot d'ordre de
grève sur les théâtres et questions que
l'on se substitue aux travailleurs pour
l'international
[Applaudissements]
en vieux routier syndicaliste c'est gai
a senti la salle les milliers de
métallos présent ne veulent pas
reprendre le travail n'ira pas contre
[Applaudissements]
après le meeting il m'a dit vraiment les
salariés ils en veulent oui il ya eu un
peu de surprises pour ce que je me
souviens parce que
[Musique]
nous pensons au parti communiste et la
direction de la cgt on pensait que les
choses seraient reçus de la meilleure
façon je suis allé parler à la régie
nationale renault en sachant qu'avant
mon arrivée les travailleurs avaient
voté la poursuite de la grève sur la
base des informations qu'ils avaient
entendu sur leurs transistors y compris
les déclarations que j'avais faite
simultanément à celle de georges
pompidou au ministre au ministère du
travail je suis allé parler à ce métier
avec le souci de faire un compte-rendu
objectifs de l'état de la négociation
des concessions que nous avions hawk
imposé et des points sur lesquels il
restait à faire subir au gouvernement la
pression pour les plus loin j'ai fait
applaudir les concessions j'ai fait
siffler l'intransigeance du gouvernement
sur ces problèmes là je pense avoir
accompli normalement ma mission
syndicale et si c'était à refaire je
referais la même chose même si certains
ont interprété ces sifflets comme une
condamnation de la position de la cgt
renault est le phare de la classe
ouvrière la grève reconduite dans l'île
seguin c'est un signe pour les grandes
entreprises en fin de matinée on ne
signale aucune reprise importante
matignon doit se rendre à l'évidence
grenelle a échoué ses cuisses ou pire
pompidou
le lundi matin aux alentours de 10
heures du matin l'un politique de
georges pompidou s'effondrait et il
fallait donc faire autre chose charles
de gaulle à penser que
la stratégie de pompidou
était que
depuis que cette stratégie avait été
adoptée et annoncer le 11 mai au soir
elle n'avait que subi des échecs ne vais
pas eu le moindre commencement de succès
et que les d'échec en échec parce que en
face on demandait toujours davantage
plus on accordait et plus il était
demandé donc il n'y avait pas de raison
que ça
l'après midi se tient un conseil des
ministres le climat est sinistre de
gaulle semblent absents indifférent il
retrouve juste de l'énergie pour
protester contre l'autorisation donnée à
la tenue d'un meeting au stade charléty
en fin d'après midi
[Musique]
les 30000 personnes présentes ne doute
pas du sens de l'histoire elles
brandissent le drapeau rouge et ne croit
qu'à la révolution mais elle ignore le
sens de la manoeuvre l'idée de ce
rassemblement a été lancé par les
modérés du mouvement de mai autour du
psu et de la cfdt
des hommes comme michel rocard qui
cherchent une issue politique impôts
entre le gauchisme et la gauche entre
l'illusion lyrique et les réalités
[Musique]
un homme incarne cette transition ce
trait d'union entre les révolutionnaires
raisonnable elle réformiste raisonneur
il y a manèges france observateur
discret donc ça veut bien dire en effet
que là il peut y avoir un pont il peut
être l'homme qui fasse le pont entre les
mouvements gauchistes earth guillemets
et le une gouvernement de gauche qui
prendrait la succession charléty était
le dirait la pointe extrême de cette
tentative de
de construction d'une
débouché politique
ps ce centre
offert au mouvement au mouvement social
est évidemment la réaction du parti
communiste l'égard de charléty a été
extrêmement négative extrêmement dur
en fait c'était un rassemblement
politique
dans lequel l'adversaire principal
c'était la série tu es parti
aux yeux des communistes mendès-france
est un homme seul sans parti sans
appareil sans troupe à cet instant de la
crise il incarne un danger immense
donner une voix une réalité une
espérance un mouvement qui se cherche
tout plutôt que mades pense le pcf
[Musique]
le 28 mai françois mitterrand qui
n'était pas au stade charléty entre en
piste le candidat de la gauche unie en
1965 est convaincu que face à un pouvoir
qui s'effondre il faut affirmer une
alternative
[Musique]
en france depuis le 3 mai 1968 il n'y a
plus d'état
et ce qui en tient lieu ne dispose même
pas des apparences du pouvoir
tous les français savent que le
gouvernement actuel est incapable de
résoudre la crise qui l'a provoquée
et qu'il en est réduit à agiter la
menace du désordre dont il est le vrai
responsable
pour tenter de se maintenir en place
quelques semaines encore moi j'ai
simplement dessiner le schéma que
devrait à mon sens suivre les
institutions si dans une situation
extraordinaire démission d'un président
leur public de la taille de gaulle
confusion et impuissance gouvernementale
le pays se trouvait désormais sans point
c'est tout
et qui sera président de la république
souverainement et librement le suffrage
universel le dira mais d'ores et déjà
pour votre information
je vous annonce parce que le terme
éventuel et à 18 jours
et parce que c'est le même combat je
suis candidat je me soumettait à la
règle du jeu qu'en consommer de récuser
les communistes sont pas heureux d'être
mis devant le fait accompli il ne croit
pas au vide du pouvoir mais ils ne
veulent pas être absents au kazoo à la
fois méfiance même hostilité à l'égard
de l'entreprise mythe et ambre de france
est le cas du maire
mais en même temps
souci de ne pas se couper complètement
de d'une alternance politique
on tombe pouvait pas savoir ce qu'elle
allait devenir
[Musique]
le face à face entre mitterrand et le pc
temps du waldeck rochet revendique plus
de place pour les communistes dans le
futur gouvernement
[Musique]
mitterrand reste dans le flou mais là
obtenu l'essentiel le pc marche avec lui
il ya une discussion au comité central
et
un avis favorable a été donné à une
participation à cette entreprise en
cette construction d'alternatives
politiques
mais pour bien montrer sa force surtout
à ses alliés le parti communiste
convoque une grande manifestation pour
le lendemain 29 mai officiellement c'est
la cgt qui défilera
[Musique]
m
dans la soirée du 28 et ralliement à
mitterrand se multiplient
pendant les deux jours qui ont suivi
c'est un triomphe on sort alliés et ci
ou là le nombre de ceux qui au niveau
des responsabilités politiques ou au
niveau des cabinets
sont allés
honteusement je dirais l'oreille basséen
rasant les murs dap et aux portes des
collaborateurs monsieur mitterrand elle
était sans aucun doute important et
comme tout se sait naturellement cela
s'est su ne comptez pas sur moi pour
citer à cet égard des souvenirs cela il
ya prescription bien entendu et du côté
gaulliste proprement dit cela commençait
aussi à bouger
de même qu'il y avait certains membres
du gouvernement certains gaullistes
fameux qui étaient engagés dans une
négociation parallèle est secrète avec
plusieurs dirigeants communistes de la
cgt de même il y avait des gaullistes
qui préparer l'avenir en essayant de
traiter avec ceux qui avaient rasé comme
le futur pouvoir il y avait si l'on veut
une sorte de liquéfaction de l'état
parce que on sentait que toutes les
initiatives qu'ils avaient prise du
gouvernement se retourner contre lui et
les gens y compris des fonctionner
prenait des dispositions
pour s'assurer auprès du pouvoir du
lendemain dans ces cas là on pense
toujours pouvoir du lendemain et le
pouvoir du lendemain ça devait être à
gauche
le pouvoir semble frapper de paralysie
dans les hautes sphères de l'état c'est
la panique
l'elysée n'en voyais plus rien
pour ce qui concerne les aides quand les
téléphones étaient était complètement
muet nous étions nous étions isolés on
avait il faut bien le dire une
atmosphère de fin de règne il y avait
bien des gentils et est passé
sous la carpette et sous le molleton de
carpète dire d'autre qui avait quitté
paris
d'autres qui étaient vraiment dans leur
bureau mais aux abonnés absents
impuissant le gouvernement est de
surcroît ridiculiser le 28 au soir cohn
bendit interdit de séjour mais tu as an
douar faire retour triomphal à la
sorbonne
[Musique]
demain je le reste pour ça tu as fait
rentrer la pays arabes sans vol
puisqu'il a causé du désordre de l'ordre
public en france soit expulsé dimanche
je manque que celui qui a pris la
décision de m'expulser il a causé le
désordre public dans les rues de paris
qu'il soit excusé devant même site est
touché
c'est vrai que c'est un grand moment
entre guillemets pour moi c'est à dire
c'est
un moment où sent plus pisser et d'un
autre côté ça a été très tragique parce
que ça compte ça m'a fait complètement
dérapé c'est à dire que j'étais plus
capable de gérer moi-même mon personnage
le 29 mai à 7h30 le général de gaulle
convoque son directeur de cabinet et
l'informent qu'il part se reposer à
colombes et
un peu plus tard le chef de l'état
transmis au secrétaire général de
l'elysée bernard tricot ces instructions
le conseil des ministres qui devait se
tenir ce matin là comme tous les
mercredi est reporté au lendemain 15h
vers alemany je ne dors plus ici j'ai
besoin de me refaire à la campagne
prenez me dit il
dans ce cas tarja sans que l'on vous
voit des cartes plus à l'est de colombes
et sans explication et rendez moi
content quand je pourrai partie
vers 11 heures le téléphone sonne dans
le bureau du premier ministre au bout du
fil il reconnaît la voix du général je
pars pour colombes et je reviendrai
demain prévient le chef de l'état
j'étais dans le bureau de georges
pompidou alors qu'on vit tous reposent
de téléphone il me dit il m'embrasse
alors qu'il était passé à ses fins et
avisé général n'avait jamais utilisé ce
ce vocabulaire avec lui même s'il y
avait eu de l'affectivité entre n'avait
jamais dit à georges pompidou je vous
embrasse il m'a suffi de quelques
quelques minutes pour prendre les cartes
pour m'assurer que toutes les
dispositions ont été prises par mes
camarades fait remettre la voiture du
général dans le parc pour partir et je
suis rentré dans son bureau je lui ai
dit mon général vous pourrez partir à 11
heures casse et à 11h15 le général a
quitté l'élysée par le parc et par la
ruse marigny
à midi sur l'héliport d'issy les
moulineaux le président de la république
son épouse et sa suite embarquent à bord
d'hélicoptères alouette iii général et
nerveux il maugrée parce qu'il ya trop
de bagages beaucoup plus que d'habitude
le cap est mis sur saint dizier à 50 km
au nord de colombo
le plein fait l'appareil redécolle vers
l'est
et j'ai dit au pilate
initiative ni volé bas sous les radars
de façon qu'on ne détecte pas le
résultat est que les radars
de l'armée de l'air qui suivent l
hélicoptère le perdre de vue et dans la
demi-heure qui suit le chef d'état major
de l'armée de l'air bappel sur sa ligne
directe et me dit monsieur le ministre
nous avons perdu l'hélicoptère le
général de gaulle
ma réaction était que hélicoptère
s'était écrasé et jeu s'appelle georges
pompidou odier t on à matignon il dit
chercher obligé de vous annoncer que les
radars ont perdu l'hélicoptère général
de gaulle sa formule 1
dans l'appareil le bruit interdit le
dialogue le général griffonne sur une
enveloppe résidence du commandant en
chef des forces françaises en allemagne
et l'attend un flot hic assis à l'avant
la destination est donc baden-baden
j'arrive
se pose alors d'un des hélicoptères sort
le général est malade de gone
garde à vous salue
nice a lancé bini massue tout est foutu
les communistes ont tout au tout bloquer
alors je viens chez vous pour voir et
j'ai entendu ma su lui répondre
un homme de votre prestige a encore des
moyens d'action
donc à mon sens la chair était gagné
c'était la réponse qu'il fallait au
général alors j'ai compris tout de suite
qu'il n'était pas dans son état normal
quelque chose qui ne tourne pas bien des
parents et
[Musique]
je me suis dit il faut essayer
d'arranger les choses mais entre nous je
vois un peu plus clair d'abord sur des
murs qui pense ce qu'il veut mais
surtout que ça reste strictement non pas
le cas de jacques daoust alors j'ai
bloqué tout à fait le toute relation
avec l'extérieur
plusieurs indices montrent que le
général de gaulle a pris des
dispositions pour un séjour prolongé en
allemagne son fils et sa famille sont
venus le rejoindre à baden madame de
gaulle a commencé à installer ses
bagages dans une chambre mais surtout le
chef de l'état français veut faire
prévenir les autorités allemandes de sa
présence sur leur territoire
[Musique]
je ne crois pas qu'il voulait rester là
quand j'ai fait mon siège police hendaye
et je lui ai dit des choses assez dur on
trouve qu'il n'est pas loin de 6 9 en
droit de laisser tomber évidemment je
comprends très bien qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient fatigués de cette de cette
chirurgie à un moment donné j'ai senti
que ce que je lui disais une faisait du
bien parce que il m'a dit continuez
continuez alors j'en ai j'en ai un peu
rajouté
alors bon bah il a digéré un petit peu
tout ça et puis
il m'a dit
bon ben je cherchais ma femme
je répare on les a mis dans leurs
hélicoptères et puis
et puis on l'attend dictature des puits
de coeur serré on les a vus partir
on a soufflé
vers 18 heures le général de gaulle est
à colombey
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que nous sommes entrés à la
boisserie générale aussitôt téléphoné à
bernard tricot en lui disant fin comme
prévu conseil des ministres demain de
magasins quand il m'a appelé ce devait
être vers les 18 heures 18 heures 15
ans ce jour là j'ai trouvé un homme je
dirais qu'il allait de mieux en mieux et
je lui ai dit assez carrément que le
fait pour lui d'avoir disparu pendant
quelques heures avait été pour le
gouvernement et puis pour ses
collaborateurs de l'elysée très dures
épreuves
et que ça vraiment nous avions été dans
une drôle de situation
il c'est au cours de cet entretien qu'il
a eu cette formule je me suis mis
d'accord avec mes arrières pensées et
j'ai eu l'impression à ce moment-là
qu'il qu'il était décidé à reprendre les
affaires en main
un pari le premier ministre a appris la
disparition du général vers 14 heures
pendant de longues heures il reste dans
l'ignorance de l'endroit où se trouve
son président
et qu'à matignon tout le monde
s'interroge soit alors pour un préfet de
police c'est très surprenant soit de
voir que le chef du gouvernement et tout
l'entourage élyséen ne savent pas où est
passé le président de la république
française c'est un moment
troupes le rang
[Applaudissements]
les dirigeants communistes apprennent
que de gaulle a disparu au moment même
où s'ébranla manifestations de la cgt
[Applaudissements]
je pense que la direction du parti
communiste on a toujours considéré on a
considéré que c'était une feinte nous
n'avons jamais pensé que le pouvoir
était vacant j'arrive je crois qu'on n'a
jamais cru qu'il ait abandonné la partie
comme ça
et il y a eu au contraire une réaction
d'extrême méfiance et d'extrême prudence
le climat dans paris est étrange le
temps semble suspendu la foule est
énorme quatre cent mille personnes
défilent en criant gouvernement
populaire le parti communiste montre sa
force sur le terrain aucune sortie de
crise à gauche ne se fera sans lui
dans toute ma vie je n'ai pas participé
quelque chose c'était une manifestation
puissante on estimé qu'il y avait cinq
cent mille personnes
dans un paris vide
l'impression
c'était quand même 29 mai faisait beau
sur les boulevards pas pas de police pas
de crs rien
l'impression d'être dans un pays conquis
dans les sphères du pouvoir les
informations circulent en redoute que le
pc transforme la manifestation en
insurrection et s'empare de l'elysée
et dans le grand défilé de la cgtr nous
parlons on me met en garde sérieusement
mais on a des raisons de penser que la
cgt a déjà des troupes armées
honnêtement j'ai jamais pris ces
choses-là au sérieux parce que ça ne
résistait pas à l'analyse le parti
communiste dès le début dès le début
avait bien vu que son principal
adversaire
c'était des vosges schiste vraiment de
c'était vraiment la plaie et la
catastrophe
il aimait infiniment mieux gouvernement
moulis que que que le triomphe des des
gauchistes
dans l'étrange atmosphère de ce jour
dans le grand vide créé par le départ du
général les potez mendès france prend de
la consistance
toute l'après-midi du 29 la montée vers
le pouvoir de pmf semble irrésistible
les ralliements à sa personne prenne
l'alluré d'un raz-de-marée il occupe
carrefour stratégique où tout converge
de l'extrême gauche aux gaullistes dans
la soirée manet se décide et se jette à
l'eau
il est bien tard la radio a annoncé le
retour du général à colombey
or un grain de folie à une folle journée
des rumeurs de mouvements de troupes
circulent dans paris ces rumeurs ne sont
pas dénuées de fondement plusieurs
unités blindées ont été mises en état d'
alerte à tout hasard
nous avions simplement sur le terrain
des gens qui rapporte
des déplacements des agitations
les choses qui se passaient dans
différentes casernes
dans la grande périphérie parisienne des
unités
cantonné dans les environs de paris
était en état d' alerte permanente mais
l'armée proprement dite n'a jamais été
engagée alors que la question s'est
posée plusieurs fois j'avais amené une
brigade de de régiment de parachutistes
ou près de paris a fait 2 et jamais ces
régimes en ont été engagés bien ta
question mme été déposé à plusieurs
reprises
c'était évident que ces possibilités là
existaient le gouvernement avait ses
possibilités là au cas où quelque chose
aurait donné un prétexte pour le faire
il y avait risque
si nous n'avions pas eu le sang froid
que nous avons eue
le jeudi 30 au matin dans le silence de
la boisserie général de gaulle rédige le
texte de l'allocution qu'il a
l'intention de prononcer l'après midi
même à la radio puis en fin de matinée
ayant chaussé des bottes de 40 du
regagne paris fait par bernard tricot de
ses intentions il a décidé de rester ils
gardent pompidou il fait le référendum
vous
on
alors j'ai téléphoné à georges pompidou
je lui ai dit cela et même il faut
absolument je vois le général avant le
conseil des ministres
car moi je veux partir je lui en veux de
nous avoir laissés dans l'ignorance de
l'endroit où était le chef de l'état ce
qui est une situation
vraiment tout à fait exceptionnel on ne
pas dire plus je vais me retirer ça fait
d'ailleurs longtemps je suis premier
ministre il était point unique depuis
soixante
en début d'après-midi pompidou arrive à
l'elysée il a sa lettre de démission
dans sa poche
il n'en est pas question tranche général
kili à son premier ministre le texte de
son discours
alors quand pidoux plutôt que le
référendum prévu plaide pour la
dissolution de l'assemblée mais de
gaulle tient au référendum car lui seul
peut à ses yeux rétablir sa légitimité
aux puits d'eau argumente si le
référendum est perdu si vous conduisez
en cas d'élection ce n'est que moi
et si les élections sont gagnées riposte
de gaulle
alors pour pie xii sort sa dernière
carte mon général vous me demandez de
rester je vous demande la dissolution de
gaulle s'incline
j'ai vu le manuscrit de son texte qui
est absolument certain indubitable il
avait été écrit
pour annoncer à référendum et puis il
n'a barré dernier moment pour annoncer
des élections législatives et à la
phrase était pas très bien monté mon vin
il avait suivi le français ne sont pas
nui
pompidou a obtenu satisfaction les
élections législatives
c'est son affaire
à 16h30 après un conseil des ministres
mené au galop de gaulle parle
françaises sont celles où tant le
développeur de la légitimité nationale
et richesse
j'ai envisagé depuis 24 heures les
éventualités sans exception qui me
permettrait un impie
j'ai pris mes résolutions
dans les circonstances présentes je
under
je ne changerai pas le premier league
je dissous aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale
[Applaudissements]
quatre minutes et demie et en quatre
minutes et demie il a tout dit c'était
une sorte de salle phrase d'une force
incroyable
jeudi avec sa
renforcer notre notre admiration à
l'égard des personnes âgées son discours
du 30 mai était une parole fausses qui
sonnait juste parce que ils avaient
l'air de dire que c'est de la faute des
communistes alors que les communistes
avaient pas cessé de manifester qui
souhaitait que le gouvernement se tire
d'affaires est de faire le nécessaire
pour ça
c'étaient les seuls seraient
gouvernement s'appuyer dans cette
période et
c'était donc une parole fausse mais en
même temps c'était du bar qui
correspondait exactement à ce qu'on
attendait on voulait qu'ils tapent du
poing sur la table qui se disent des
choses claires et nettes c'est ce qu'il
a fait et en quatre minutes il avait un
appel qui a été aussi décisif que
l'appel du 18 juin
de gaulle a montré le vide pour mieux le
remplir dès la fin du discours la foule
afflue place de la concorde où de vieux
briscards du gaullisme ont prévu depuis
plusieurs jours une manifestation les
attendent cinquante mille personnes
[Applaudissements]
je le revois encore derrière ses
fenêtres de son bureau qui donne sur le
parc de l'elysée les fenêtres étaient
ouvertes nous faisait beau et il
regardait vers l'est après ce discours
je pars vers l'est 17h30 18h la foule
qui commence à monter les champs elysées
mais les choses se présentent bien bien
beaucoup de monde une défileront au
moins jusqu'à 8 heures du soir
[Musique]
lamari golly submerge de champs elysées
guidés par une paie de ministres et de
parlementaires de gaulle n'est pas seul
crie la foule ils seront moins 500
milles avec lui l'homme du 18-juin jouer
à parler à gagner
[Musique]
puis au fur et à mesure que nous avons
sur lentement sur les champs elysées il
arrivait de gens de tous côtés et alors
nous sommes dit c'est gagné ça veut dire
que tout paris vient de paris reflux
[Musique]
était ce un homme brisé qui a été
remonté au moins temporairement par le
général massu à baden baden
était ce un froid calculateur en plein
pot de ses moyens qui a monté un
scénario destiné à impressionner le
peuple français a provoqué un
retournement psychologique
eh bien je dois dire que je ne le sais
pas
[Musique]
en juin commence l'agonie de mai comme
par miracle les sens revient pour le
week-end de pâques cours il y aura des
dizaines de tués sur les routes
[Musique]
allonger le lundi la reprise du travail
commence d'abord très lente mais le 5
juin des transports reprennent bus
métros trains fonctionnent après trois
semaines d'interruption paris retrouve
son visage habituel
c'est l'été
les vacances
des négociations très dures continue
dans la métallurgie les étudiants les
plus radicaux refusant de voir que la
fête est finie convergent là où la grève
dure à flins de violents affrontements
se déroulent entre les grévistes appuyé
par les étudiants et les forces de
l'ordre
[Musique]
un jeune lycéen gilles totain se noie en
voulant échapper aux gendarmes mobiles
lendemain les ouvriers peugeot
affrontent les crs qui ont fait évacuer
les usines de sochaux un ouvrier pierre
belleau et tué par une balle de 9 mm un
autre ouvrier henry blanche est
déséquilibré par le souffle d'une
explosion s'est tué en tombant des nues
cela fait trois morts en deux jours
alors que le pouvoir n'est plus en jeu
les fans grève sont meurtrières
pour protester l'unef appelle à une
manifestation
ce sera la dernière de mai où six
violentes qu'inutile ces barricades pour
rien grossistes le parti de l'ordre le
gouvernement dissout les groupes
gauchistes la révolution s'estompe dans
des brumes nostalgique
[Musique]
les derniers vestiges du joli mois de
mai disparaissent le gouvernement fait
évacuer l'eau des ans le 14 juin les
occupants qui avait eu le temps de
refaire plusieurs fois le monde
s'épanouisse
[Musique]
le 16 c'est autour de la sorbonne est
évacué le printemps des enragés s'achève
sur un grand nettoyage
renault la citadelle ouvrière pour
ouvert la marche ferme le ban le 18 le
travail reprend à l'île seguin par un
défilé de victoires que certains
trouvent amer
à la fin du mois la plus grande grève de
l'histoire est terminée reste à
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
à la télévision le chef de l'état ne
manque pas de lucidité rétrospective
comment vous avez une société je parle
de la société française
voilà une société
dans laquelle la machine est la
maîtresse absolue
et la pousse à un rythme accéléré
dans des transformations in will
une société
dans laquelle tout ce qui est énorme
matériel
les conditions du travail l'existence
ménagères les déplacements l'information
et cetera
tout cela qui n'avait pas bougé depuis
l'antiquité change maintenant
de plus en plus rapidement et de plus en
plus complètement
une société
qui ya 50 ans était agricole et
villageoises et qui à toute vitesse tu
deviens industrielle et urbaine
une société qui a perdu en grande partie
les fondements et l'encadrement sociaux
moraux religieux
qui lui étaient traditionnel une société
qui
actuellement
disposent
d'une information dans les moyens sont
colossaux qui agissent à chaque minute
et qui s'emploie
essentiellement vous savez bien
contre toute autorité a commencé s'il
vous plaît par la mienne et qui tapent
sans relâche et presque exclusivement
sur le sensationnel le dramatique le
douloureux le scandaient lé
cours est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
cette société là
soient placés et soit au fond satisfaite
elle ne l'est certainement pas
comment
trouver un équilibre humains
pour la civilisation pour la société
mécanique moderne
voilà la grande question de ce siècle
place aux élections georges pompidou bat
les estrades il mène la campagne de la
majorité gaulliste en jouant du réflexe
de peur
les repoussaient l'anarchie si vous
voulez repousser la subversion si vous
voulez barrer la route un parti
totalitaire qui menace nos libertés
accordées vos suffrages dès le premier
tour massivement aux candidats qui sont
investis par l'union pour la défense de
la république
le premier ministre attac celui qui
finalement fut son meilleur allié le
parti communiste et l'accusent de
subversion
c'est un peu gros mais seul le résultat
compte
la vague dollis défaire dans les urnes
la gauche reculent de 5 points on n'a
pas vu une majorité aussi large depuis
le second empire le parti de l'ordre
rempile hémicycle
georges pompidou le vainqueur des
élections l'homme qui a tenu bon dans la
tempête et remplacé par couve de
murville de gaulle n'a pas oublié les
désaccords de mai le chantage à la
démission brandi deux fois par pompidou
et 11 et 30 mai surtout il ne peut
supporter que s'affirme une autre
légitimité que la sienne qui existent en
quelque sorte un président bis
[Musique]
le fait que après 68 le premier ministre
qui avait très bien conduit le bateau de
gouvernement dans cette période très
difficile
soit devenu l'homme auquel les français
attribuent est le principal mairie de la
sortie de crise lui paraissait
profondément
contradictoire avec la philosophie de la
vème république
au lendemain de mai de gaulle veut
réformer la société française il parle
de participation et de décentralisation
mais l'assemblée de la peur plus qu'un
grand dessein recherche un gros gourdin
une majorité élue en 68 a comme
principal souci de de tirer un trait sur
ce qui s'est passé au mois de mai et de
faire comme si rien ne s'était passé
le 14 juillet comme tous les ans l'armée
défilent devant le chef de l'état et son
premier ministre tout semble rentrer
dans l'ordre en apparence car à défaut
d'une révolution introuvables ou
impossible la révolution des moeurs va
changer la vie des français mai 68 va
irradier la société il y aura bien un
avant et un après
quant au vieil homme rétabli in extremis
par un coup de génie il est
définitivement ébranlé il a douté de lui
douté de sa capacité à guider ce pays et
l'a vu ce lien magique et mystique qui
le liait depuis quarante aux français se
distendre quelques mois plus tard
lorsqu'il voudra restaurer sa légitimité
par le référendum il tirera non sans
grandeur les leçons de son échec
[Musique]
oui